hi i'm jonathan and i'm going to be
talking about the paper
interactive proof for verifying machine
learning
this is a joint work with shafi
goldwater guy ross bloom
and emilio dayoff and the question we
considered
was one is verifying
troopers and learning what i mean by
this is the following
so we're all familiar with the
idea that sometimes solving a certain
problem can be harder
than verifying a solution provided by
someone else
and that's of course a central theme in
computational complexity the p versus
np problem and so on but what about
supervised machine learning are there
supervised machine learning problems
where finding a good hypothesis
is hard but verifying
a hypothesis provided by someone else is
easy
so that's the question we considered and
of course we're interested in knowing
are there cases like that when when is
it easier to verify than it is to learn
how much easier it is and so on
the the setting we used is the following
setting
so there's some unknown distribution
that provides um
samples of the form x and y where x is
some instance
and y is the label for that instance
and there's a verifier which
has the objective of finding some
hypothesis
is that is good at predicting the labels
predicting y given x
the verifier can take random samples
from the distribution
but it doesn't want to do all the hard
work of finding the hypothesis itself
instead it's gonna use the help of
another party which we call the learners
approver
and that party maybe has a lot more
computational resources or
and stuff like that and the verifier
wants to use the health of the food in
order to find
a good hypothesis so
the the approver can also take
samples from the unknown distribution
and the verified approval can exchange
messages and at the end of the
interaction after they finish sending
messages to each other
the verifier will either reject the
interaction
or it will accept the interaction and
output some hypothesis
so for example um maybe the
approver will take samples from the
distribution
and run some machine learning algorithm
find a good hypothesis
using those samples and sends a
hypothesis there's a message to the
verify
then the verifier takes additional
samples of its own from the distribution
and uses them in order to decide whether
this hypothesis is good or not good
and after it does that it either outputs
the hypothesis if it thinks it's good
or it rejects so that's generally the
the type of interactive proof we're
considering
in this paper and we're asking one is
the
um work that the verifier does
cheaper than just learning the
hypothesis
itself without using the help of the of
some external proofer
and when i say cheaper i mean both
quantitatively so for instance maybe the
verifier needs less samples in order to
do the verification
than it would if it was uh just doing
learning by itself
and so this is number of samples runtime
etc or it could be qualitatively cheaper
for instance maybe the verifier uses
uh some sort of cheaper access to the
distribution
so for instance maybe the verifier has
random sample access to
a distribution that provides a sample to
the form
x and f of x while uh
the approver has query access to that
labeling function
f which is a stronger and more expensive
type of access
so then develop the verifier would gain
the benefit of
finding a good hypothesis without
needing to have that more expensive kind
of access itself
um so that's generally our setting
and let's do an example
of uh when this kind of setting might be
useful so imagine some sort of
commercial situation where you have uh
one company v the verifier and they have
some
machine learning tasks that they want to
solve but instead of solving it
themselves they outsource
their machine learning work to some
prover p which is a machine learning
services provider
and what the provider supposedly does
is it it's what it's supposed to do is
to
collect a lot of high quality data
related to this particular machine
learning problem
and you know train a good machine
learning model for that data maybe using
a lot of compute
power maybe you know some deep neural
networks whatever
and then it will send that hypothesis to
the verify
back to the the companies that ordered
them
and now the verifier receives the model
and it sees that the model has an
accuracy eighty percent
they can predict you know the correct uh
label y with eighty percent
uh probability and like
verifying that it's about eighty percent
is easy just you know
take a hundred samples or something like
that and uh
see what percent of those samples are
labeled correctly by the model and
that's a pretty good estimate of the
correct uh true accuracy of the model
but if v knows that the accuracy is 80
percent
it's still not clear if if we should
accept or not
if 80 good enough not good enough maybe
the provider was slacking off and they
could have gotten to 90
if they would have done more work um
so in order to um define this a bit more
formally we followed the
definition of probably approximately
correct
pac learning which is a very common
definition in learning theory
and the way this um
definition works is we have some class h
of functions um x
functions from the domain x to zero one
and the sum lost functions that for each
hypothesis
h in the class little h in the class big
h
tells us how good a bad little h
performs so for instance
this particular loss function here which
is what we'll mostly work with is the
zero
one loss it says what is the probability
that h
uh classifies x incorrectly predicts the
wrong label
and then there's this number here opt
which is
the uh best possible loss you can
achieve
if you're using hypotheses from
the class h this is the minimum loss you
can achieve
if you're using hypotheses from age
and we say that a class and big h
is pac-learnable if there exists an
algorithm such that for every epsilon
and delta and every
unknown distribution if we execute this
algorithm with samples from the
distribution
then um with high probability the result
is approximately correct
it's probably approximately correct so
with probability of
at least one minus delta the loss of
h the output is the most epsilon voicing
than the optimum loss so
kind of inspired by this definition of
path learning
we introduced the following definition
that we call
pac verification and it goes this
following we say that a
class of functions h is pack verifiable
if there exists two algorithms a
verifier
and approval such that for every epsilon
and delta for every unknown distribution
d
uh the verified approval satisfy
completeness and soundness
completeness means that if i run the
verify and approver so that they
interact with each other
and they have sample access to the
distribution and so on
then with high probability probability
at least one minus delta
um the verifier will not reject the
interaction
and it will output a hypothesis h as it
is
approximately approximately correct so
it has
loss at most oct plus epsilon
that's completeness soundness
means that for any prover maybe a
different
dishonest malicious and possibly
computationally unbounded prover
so for any prover uh if that prover
interacts with
with uh the verifier and they both have
access to the distribution and so on
then this malicious prover cannot cause
the verifier
to output a hypothesis that is not
approximately correct except maybe with
some small probability
so the verifier will either reject the
interaction
or will output a good hypothesis or
with very very small probability it will
output a bad hypothesis
so that's a soundness and
we're particularly interested in cases
that satisfy
double efficiency so what we mean by
that is that
both the verifier and approver need to
be
the honest prover needs to be efficient
so
the dishonest malicious mover might be
computationally unbounded but we want
both the verifier
and the honest prover to be uh efficient
and the um motivation for that
is that we want um for instance like we
saw in the
in the commercial setting we want some
you know actual real party to be able to
uh uh instantiate the approval and uh
run that algorithm and so on
so um in order to allow you know the
the machine learning provider to execute
the approval we want the prover to be
efficient
so that's uh our definition of path
verification
and the first thing to observe about
our definition of fact verification
is that in the realizable case
when um
[Music]
when we assume that oct is zero zen
verification is easy
so if if we are promised there exists
some hypothesis in the class that has
zero loss then path verification is easy
and why is that so
uh generally if uh what the verifier
does
is it can take order one over epsilon
random samples and it will accept the
hypothesis that
the proven provides if and only if uh
that hypothesis classifies all the
um instances in the sample correctly
and so um if the
uh approval was honest and it's some
hypothesis that had zero loss
then the verifier will always accept and
in fact even if the
prover sent hypothesis that has you know
only very close to zero
slightly more than zero but close to
zero off then
still the verifier will accept this high
probability
however if the approval sense hypothesis
is a has a loss that is too great
bigger than epsilon then the
verifier works will reject with constant
probability
so what we see is basically a separation
here between
learning and verification so in the
realizable case
it's possible to do verification using
order 1 over epsilon samples
however we know from learning theory
that
in order to do pac learning in the
realizable case we need order d over
epsilon
samples where d is the vc dimension of
the hypothesis class
capital h um and
this vc dimension is unbounded it could
be
an integer as large as we like
and so this this basically means that
the gap between learning and verifying
can be
unbounded at least in the realizable
case
so that's a nice encouraging results
that shows that maybe
we could get um nice separation results
like this
but it's not very surprising for the
realizable case
things become a bit more interesting in
the agnostic case so
in the agnostic case we're not making
any assumptions
about opt the the best loss that we can
achieve
using our class and so
basically what the verifier needs to do
is it needs to verify that this
inequality holds
for the hypothesis h that is proposed by
the prover
and as we uh sort of already discussed
estimating the left hand side here the
loss of the
particular hypothesis is easy just you
know take 100 samples
and see what percentage of them are
labeled correctly by this hypothesis and
that's a very good estimate
um the problem is that the verifier
doesn't know what opt is
and so this is where the approver comes
in the approver will let's say send
the hypothesis to the verifier and then
it will
interact in an interactive proof with
the verifier in order to convince the
verifier
that opt is large it's large enough to
make this inequality hold
so that's basically what the prover
needs to do it needs to
be able to prove that oct is right
and now let's see example where this is
actually
possible in the agnostic case so
this is a very simple example and
the main point is that we are able to
get a separation between the sample
complexity of learning and verification
also in the
agnostic case so the class of hypothesis
that we're using is this class
uh of monotone increasing boolean first
also it's just like
um threshold functions like this that
start off as being zero zero zero and
then at some point they jump up
and continue to be one one one from
there on
so this is our class of hypothesis
and um
the prover sends some particular
hypothesis and it wants to convince us
that that's a good hypothesis
and therefore it needs to show the opt
is large
so let's assume that opt equals the loss
of
f t for some threshold function
t that we don't know what it is the
verifier doesn't know what it is
but we can assume that there exists some
uh
threshold like that that receives the
minimal loss
how will the prover convince to verify
that octave life
so we call this a certificate of large
loss for thresholds
and the way this works is the following
the approval will send
two sets a and b
such that a is some subset of the
domain 0 1 times 1
and b is some subset of the domain times
0.
um and a and b
are both intervals so we can think of a
as having a
start point and an endpoint
within the the some interval within the
zero one
interval and it's a set of points that
are all labeled as one
and again b is also an interval so the
points that are all labeled
is zero um formally
a and b are both events within
the probability space
where the unknown distribution is
defined
so p sends these two events a and b
and in addition they satisfy this
requirement
that a is to the left of b so all the
points in a
and this interval are smaller than all
the points
in the interval b and
why is this a good idea so
what the verifier can do when it
receives these two
events is it can estimate the weight of
each of them
um so you know
therefore i can take 100 samples and see
how many of them
fall inside the event a that's a good
estimate for the weight of a
and then do the same thing in order to
estimate the weight of b
and it turns out that opt is at least
the minimum of these two quantities
these two
probabilities the probability of a and
the probability of b
why is that so
it's quite simple basically if we have
some threshold function
and it labels even one point in a
correctly
and that means that we have this
threshold function and it goes up and
labels a point in a correctly
so from that point onwards everything to
the right of that point needs to be
also labeled as one because a everything
is a and a is labeled as one
so from this point and to the right
everything is labeled one
in particular that means that all the
points in b
are classified incorrectly by this
threshold so
if a cecil classifies any point in a
correctly that means it classifies all
the points in b
incorrectly and vice versa if it
classifies even one point in b correctly
that means it remained at zero up until
that point at least
and so we classified all the points in a
as zero which is incorrect
that means that uh you can't
you can't have a threshold that will uh
classify both a and b
correctly and therefore the loss of the
threshold
is the probability of the event of
misclassifying a point
is greater than the the loss of at least
a or b
the minimum between those two so
what we um get this way
is basically an interactive proof where
the
approver sends resets a and b and
um
it satisfies soundness and completeness
so if there
exists a sound it says if there exists
a certificate a and b such that
the weight of the minimum
minimum between a weight in a and weight
of b
equals l then after at least l
exactly for the reason i just stated
which is if you
classify one point in a correctly you
classify all points in b
incorrectly then completeness says
is that if opt equals l
if the best loss you can achieve is l
then there exists some certificate that
shows that or actually show something
related to that which is
the existing certificate a and b such
that the minimum weight between
a and b is at least l over two
so it's not very hard to prove both of
these
claims and using this
we can using this idea we can
prove the following results which is our
first result in the paper
and it says the following it says there
exists some sequence of classes
h1 h2 h3 and so on
such that pac learning the class hd
requires at least order d random samples
on the other hand pack verifying the
class hd is possible
using order square root of d random
samples
and furthermore both the prover and the
verifier
or efficient they run in a time
polynomial and the number of samples and
so on
um so this is basically a quantitative
separation
between learning and verifying
the idea of the proof is basically to
take the
uh thrust the certificates of
large flaws for thresholds and
generalize the idea for a class
that has vc dimension d and not a
constant dc dimension like
like the threshold have but this will be
a d threshold that has vc dimension
d and and then uh
the the certificate will be a set of
2d events instead of just two events and
the verifier will now need to verify
that
all these events satisfy some condition
that shows the octave large and it turns
out that using
ideas from distribution testing you can
actually do that using square root d
samples um so that's
that's uh the idea of our first result
uh quantitative separation between
learning and
verify a second result
is kind of the opposite it says in some
cases uh
learning and verifying or
or cost requires the same amount of
random samples they cost the same
so formally there exists a sequence of
classes h1 h2 it's three and so on
such that path learning the class hd
is possible using order d random samples
while pac verifying the class hd
requires order d random samples and so
you don't you don't get any saving by
doing
tax verification for this class and the
proof of this is uh
basically from the probabilistic method
if you
uh choose the class and according to
some
clever distribution then you uh
you you will get this result so i have
some uh
caveats um in particular so
um even though pac-running this class is
possible using
uh or to do random samples the runtime
of the algorithm that does the path
running might might not be
polynomial it might be exponential uh in
the number of samples
so the runtime is not actually efficient
and on the other hand the um
verifier and the the lower bound and
verifying only applies
to proper uh verification and
what i mean by that is that uh it only
applies to
um interactive proofs with a verifier
outputs a hypothesis that belongs to the
class hd
maybe possibly if you uh allow the
verifier to output
a hypothesis that has a low
loss but does not belong to the class hd
then
this lower bound wouldn't hold um
but that's the the overview of our
second result
and basically what we've seen so far is
that from a
quantitative point of view there are
some cases where
learning is more expensive than
verification verification is cheaper
and um in other cases that's not that's
not true in other cases they
they're both equally expensive and so it
would be very interesting to understand
when exactly this happens when is
learning
uh more expensive verification
and when one is is not
when can you save using verification and
when can you not save
in sample complexity let's say um
our third result um
is a qualitative separation so
this uh result talks about uh the class
of
the class h of t-splice boolean
functions from the boolean hypercube to
zero one
and i'll define that class in the next
slide
but the the point is sort of that
if you adopt the learning parody with
noise assumption
which is a very common assumption in
cryptography
then agnostic learning the class h from
random samples is computationally hard
um like in fact even learning just a
a single parody is hard and h
is somehow linear combinations of
parodies so that's even harder
so if if the lpn assumption
is true then it is not possible to
efficiently
agnostically pac-learn the class h
however what we prove is that
h is pack verifiable uh
using an interactive proof system with
uh the following property
so um
the verifier v uses only random samples
from the distribution
the prover has query access to the
labeling function so if the distribution
is a distribution over sample samples if
you know
x and f of x then the approver can just
query that labeling function
f on any x that it chooses
um and both the verifier and approval
are efficient they run in time
polynomial
uh in the uh parameters of the problem
and
the verify users they both use samples
or quiz
polynomials in the parameters of the
quantum problem
and so on so
basically this result is saying
um you
you cannot efficiently pack learn
this class using random samples but you
can't efficiently pack
verify this class using random samples
let's say here
and i'm going to spend the rest of the
talk
explaining a bit about this result
and then i'll wrap up
so um first of all um as promised let's
define this class
of two-spice functions so
uh for any s which is
a subset of uh the numbers between 1 and
n
we define a chi of s to be a function
from the boolean hypercube
in other words uh a vector of n bits
two um um
plus minus one and this is basically a
parity of the subset of the bits that
correspond to this
the subset s of the bits takes the
parity that's chi of s
and um
fourier analysis tells us that uh any
function
f can be written as a linear combination
of
these chi-s's we call the chi-s's
characters
and this thing here is the f-hat of
s is the fourier coefficient of
x it corresponds to this particular
chivas
so any any function boolean and any
function from the hypercube to the
wheels
can be written as a linear combination
of
characters and the class of two-splice
functions is simply
those functions were the most
t non-zero coefficients so functions
uh each of which is a linear combination
of the most t
characters and
the idea for getting this qualitative
separation
is to use two well-known algorithms the
kushi-levich-mansour algorithm
and the gold-ice-levine algorithm
and combine them in a in a certain way
that allows
the verifier to uh leverage the help of
the prover
so let's start with a refresher about
what the
crucial laboratory algorithm is so this
is an algorithm that learns the class of
t-splice functions using random samples
however under the assumption that the
target function
f the function we want to identify
and
we the the the algorithm knows in
advance
what is the set of non-zero uh
coefficients non-zero fourier
coefficients
and so basically what the algorithm
needs to do is just uh figure out what
is the value of those non-zero
coefficients but it already knows in
advance
which coefficients those those are and
this is actually
fairly uh simple to explain so i'll i'll
explain how the crucial level control
algorithm works
so what happens is that um
the the fourier coefficient of s
is uh basically the projection of f
the function f on the character or the
the
inner product between them and inner
product in this context is defined
to be uh expectation and so the
the fourier coefficient s that we want
to estimate
is actually defined to be an expectation
of some random variable
which is the product of f and chi of s
and because this product is just a
random variable which is
bounded then again if we take you know
100 samples
and we take the you know the average of
the
f of x time times the chi-s of x with
those
uh 100 samples then that would be a very
good estimate of the
of the two expectations from hosting's
inequality
so
[Music]
basically we can estimate each one of
the
required fourier coefficients in this
manner
and then and that's it you now have the
good estimates of all the fourier
coefficients and it turns out that the
the the function that you uh gives that
way is very close to the correct
function if you
take the function with all the estimated
coefficients
then that's a good estimate of of the
function f
and in fact it turns out that you don't
even
need to estimate all the fourier
coefficients that are nonzero
it's enough to estimate the heavy ones
those that are
um have absolute value at least tau for
some towels it depends on
how good of an estimate you want of the
function f
okay so that's the kuch levitzmanthur
algorithm
uh the second algorithm is the goldach
levin algorithm
uh the goldberg 11 algorithm uh
is basically uh complements the the
kuchlev muscle algorithm because it can
find this set of
heavy coefficients uh of f
so if you tell it i want to find all the
coefficients that weigh at least tau
that's what the golovkin algorithm does
however
the golden 11 algorithm requires query
access to it
um okay so using these two building
blocks
leverage from the tools it can learn the
function if you know the heavy
coefficients
and requires only random samples and the
golden 11 algorithm which can find the
heavy coefficients
but requires query access we can put
both of these together
um and uh get an interactive proof
for um uh
pac-verifying the class of t-spice
boolean functions
and the idea is okay so we use the
golden 11 algorithm to find the set of
heavy coefficients
and then once we know that set of
heavily coefficients we use the kush
levitz mansour algorithm
in order to learn the function f
the problem is that as i stated the
golden clipping
algorithm requires a query access
and so for instance the verifier can't
run both of these steps they can't run
the first step
here in this among the two steps the vel
fire cannot run the first step because
it doesn't have query access um
and so what we propose is the following
solution
um the val file is basically going to
simulate the gold islamic algorithm
and in this simulation you know it
executes the golden 7 algorithm and then
it knows okay in order to complete the
algorithm i'm going to need to query f
at these particular points
f of x1 x2 and so on what it does at
that point
it can't query f because it doesn't have
query axis it's going to take
uh some additional random samples
x sub 1 x delta 2 and so on from the
distribution because
it does have random sample axis and each
of these random samples comes
with the correct label f of x tilde one
and so on
and then what the valve fire does is
it's going to
delegate the queries that it needs to
the approver so it's going to send x1
until
xm to the approver and tell the approval
please use your
query axis and tell me what f of x1 is
what f of x2 is and so on
however in addition it's going to send
these x tilde 1 and x tilde 2 and so on
which it already knows the correct label
form
but it's going to send both the queries
and the
x's from the sample mixed together uh
to the prover so that the approval can't
know which subset of these
x's the verifier uh knows the correct
label for
and which subset it does not and
what that means is that if the prover is
honest
then what it will do is it will actually
go and query x
all these x's both the regular x's and
the external ones
and send those results the correct
values to the
uh verifier the verifier will continue
the simulation of the golden 11
algorithm and then it finds f of t the
the heavy
like it finds a set of heavy
coefficients the way it most tau
at least tau um and from that point it
can proceed on its own because the
crucial evidence monster algorithm only
requires random samples
however if the approval was uh not
honest
then that means that uh like how how is
it not honest it sends
uh some uh answers that are not correct
so instead of sending f of x it sends
you know some other value for some of
these x's
but in that case uh the verifier will
detect
uh the prover dishonest with high
probability
because uh with high probability the if
we choose you know the
the number of x tildes correctly then
with high probability
if you're dishonest enough then you're
going to hit
some of these x tildes you're going to
provide incorrect answers for some of
these x tildes
and then the verifier who knows the
correct answer will know
that the prover is cheating
and will know it needs to reject the
interaction
so that's uh
basically the idea of this qualitative
separation
um in order to show that this actually
works you need to
kind of dig deeper into the details of
how the gold icelabbing algorithm works
and shows and you need to show that you
can in fact somehow
um hide a set of
x tildes within the set of actual
queries in a way that the approver won't
be able to distinguish
which are the actual queries that the
verifier wants to know and which ones
are the decoys that are just planted
there
in order to catch it um so
that requires some additional details
we will be posting a
video additional video probably in the
comments to this video
that explains the details of that um
slightly slightly more full
more full detail um
but this is this is the basic idea of
how it works
so uh to summarize what we've seen so
far
is um the definition of
pacifistification um
and some motivation for instance uh
maybe if you want to uh have a business
that
uh you know machine learning as a
service or something you outsource
machine learning
then it might be uh useful to be able to
have a path verification interactive
proof
um then we discussed quantitative
separations
between learning and verification we saw
that for some classes verification
is cheaper requires less samples and
actually they
also requires less runtime in in that
particular example
the example of the threshold function
that the d threshold functions
um you you have a situation where the
verifier
is both it's cheaper both in samples and
in runtime
and we saw in other cases uh
for instance if you just basically
choose a random class of hypothesis
uh the verification and learning
require the same amount of samples
and additionally qualitatively
we we saw that
it's possible to learn uh
the class of uh fourier splice
boolean functions using random samples
uh only so it's
it's possible to verify that class using
random samples only
even though learning that class is
probably not possible
using random samples only according to
the
learning parity with noise assumption
and actually this class
of t-spice
boolean functions is a is a fairly
important class it contains
shallow decision trees and ac 0 circuits
and dnf formulas with small clauses
so this is actually um an interesting
example i think
and there are still a lot of interesting
uh
directions for future work so first of
all
it would be um i think very interesting
to characterize exactly when there is a
gap in sample complexity between
learning and verifying and how big
that gap is um if you think about
learning so in learning we have the the
vc dimension which kind of completely
characterizes
when pack learning is possible and how
much samples that would require when it
when it is possible
so developing something similar for
pac verification i think that would be a
very interesting direction and we've
already made
uh in subsequent work we've uh
uh already made some progress in that
direction and some small focus
[Music]
um
another direction is to show um
efficient pac verification interactive
proofs for
some real-world hypothesis classes
so for instance if you're thinking about
delegation of machine learning can you
do
um pac verification for some
actual real-world classes that people
use in
uh real-world machine learning settings
like
random foreign forests and neural
networks
uh svms and so on
um another direction
um is to develop a
verification protocols for
uh replication of scientific
publications
so this is another uh motivation that
might be interesting for
pacquiaification which is let's say
someone
publishes a paper where they did an
experiment and they say here this is our
experiment
and this is these are our results the
conclusion from the experiment and so on
so traditionally what you would do would
you go and replicate that
that paper you'd go and
repeat basically the whole experiment
independently in some other lab
and see if you get the same results but
maybe instead of just publishing the
results originally you could somehow
publish approver for the results and
that would allow people to instead of
replicating the whole experiment they
could just
replicate a smaller experiment basically
create
less samples in in their you know
replication
and then using a verifier they can
interact with the prover
and basically proves that with high
probability
the the result in the original paper was
correct even though the replication
didn't actually
uh you know do as many measurements
create as many samples and so on
so that i think is an interesting uh
direction
another thing that would be interesting
to look at is
um to consider the power of interaction
so if we allow more
uh rounds of messages being exchanged
between the approver and the verifier
does that make practice location easier
or not
um how how is the the power of path
verification related to the
number of rounds in the um
in the interactive proof
another thing that would be interesting
is to consider um
verification of other kinds of data
analysis besides
supervised machine learning so you could
think about um
dimensionality reduction or clustering
or
all sorts of other tasks that are not
supervised machine learning
um and see if you could do verification
for those tasks
as well and
[Music]
another thing you could do is you could
consider
other guarantees besides
the path guarantee so in pack what we
what we're basically verifying is that
with high probability the hypothesis has
uh low loss or high accuracy
but that's just one property that the
hypothesis can have with respect to the
unknown distribution there could be
other
properties that we want good properties
that we want the hypothesis
to have with respect to the unknown
distribution for instance nobody wants a
hypothesis to
you know be algorithmically fair in some
sense or we want it to be
safe you know it's a self-driving car
and we wanted
some some guarantees that it uh
um it's safe so those are different
kinds of properties that the hypothesis
can have with respect to the unknown
distribution
and one could imagine developing uh
verification
interactive proofs for those properties
and not for the accuracy
or in addition to the accuracy um
okay so that pretty much wraps up uh
my talk um thank you very much for
watching and we'll be um
hanging out on the slack channel and
we'll be very happy to
to answer any questions you might have
thank you